[Music]
wow
hello Welcome to Cloud next
it's wonderful to join you from New York
to begin our Global 24-hour broadcast
with Keynotes happening live here in New
York
San Francisco
Tokyo
Bengaluru and Munich
it's my pleasure now to kick off today
by welcoming Google and alphabet CEO
Sundar pichai
I'm glad that today's even spans the
globe it's a representation of the
hybrid world we live in today
we're honored to build products that
help make this hybrid reality work even
better
from Google workspace to productivity
and collaboration apps that help three
billion users
including us get things done
to the cyber security that keeps
customers safe
and we are doing it all on the cleanest
cloud in the industry
earlier this year we added 24 new
languages to Google Translate with
machine learning techniques that can
translate new languages without ever
seeing a direct translation
today we are launching translation Hub
to bring these capabilities to deliver
translation at scale for all of you
it is Google Cloud's AI agent that helps
companies translate content in over 135
languages
it takes full documents including images
and translates them while preserving
layouts and formatting
enabling researchers to share their
findings with global audiences
helps providers of good and services to
reach underserved markets
and governments to better serve all of
their constituents
translation Hub joins other AI Agents
from Google Cloud that apply AI to
Common business tasks
when more people businesses and
organizations have access to the power
of Advanced Technologies
amazing things happen
that's what I see is the future of
Google cloud and fear we are grateful
for the opportunity to partner with you
on this journey
thank you all for being part of cloud
next and back to you Thomas
now our vision for cloud computing is to
simplify all of the technology
that organizations need
making it accessible by simplification
to every organization around the world
so as you can see Google cloud is
accelerating
the transformation of global leaders
in every industry
last year at next we talked about the
five most important questions leading
companies are asking themselves
to ensure they're transforming the
fastest
we're very proud to have CEO Jim Farley
discuss the journey with us
thanks Thomas and hi everyone it's so
great to be with all of you
technology in particular digital
capability to connect a car shipping
software to cars allows us to deliver
and develop a customer relationship in
ways we've never been able to do in 119
years so this is a really big deal for
us at Ford and for me the real
revolution in Auto is digital
Google's open data Cloud enables you to
Aggregate and understand
all your data
from all your sources
in All Storage formats
from all Cloud providers
and enabling all styles of access
Google's data cloud and bigquery make it
easy for organizations to combine all
their structured data from operational
databases and software as a service
applications like workday servicenow
Adobe sap and others
with unstructured data and
semi-structured data such as log files
Google has two popular tools used by 10
million users
each month for both these styles of
analysis looker
which is widely used for governed data
access
and data Studio
a leading self-service tool for
reporting dashboards and data
visualization
today we're announcing that by unifying
them with looker and looker Studio to
give self-service analysts access to
secure and govern data along with
Enterprise support and governance
capabilities data becomes even more
powerful when it's used in concert with
AI and machine learning
let me introduce Jun Yang Google's
clouds vice president of AI and Industry
solutions to tell you more about our
vision
thank you Thomas
much the data generated these days are
videos
in the past getting useful insights from
video streams in a secure and
cost-effective manner has been
challenging
today I'm excited to announce vertex AI
Vision a fully managed end-to-end
application development environment with
vertex AI vision
developers can reduce the time required
to build and deploy computer vision
application from weeks to hours
an organization can create and run this
application at a fraction of the cost
now let's talk about developers and
business
today we're launching software delivery
Shield
which provides a fully managed
end-to-end
software supply chain security solution
from source to deployment
it has four important components
first is cloud workstations now in
public preview
instead of being just another Cloud
hosted IDE
Cloud workstations provides a secure
developer environment
especially for remote developers and
contractors who work with sensitive data
second with our assured open source
software service Google Now scans
analyzes and fuss tests over
250 of the most widely used Java and
python packages
providing you what secure software
libraries that you can depend on
third Cloud build our continuous
integration service now provides support
for salsa level 3 compliance by default
salsa is an emerging open standard to
ensure that the software you use or your
software supply chain is secure fourth
the new gke Security Management
dashboard
provides you with opinionated guidance
to improve the security posture of your
container workloads Cloud infrastructure
needs to change in two fundamental ways
first customers increasingly want to use
cloud infrastructure for new types of
workloads
second with Moore's Law slowing new
infrastructure advances are required to
deliver performance improvements
we call this at Google
workload optimized infrastructure and
we're optimizing for seven key workloads
we're also creating web 3 optimized
infrastructure
web 3 leaders like near nansen Solana
block demon Dapper labs and Sky Mavis
use Google Cloud so they can focus on
innovation
and today I'm excited to announce an
important new partnership with coinbase
let's welcome coinbase CEO Brian
Armstrong to share more
I started coinbase with a desire to
create a more accessible Financial
system for everyone and Google's history
of supporting open source and
decentralized ecosystems made this a
natural fit
with this partnership with Google Cloud
we've now been able to power some of
that with coinbase cloud and so those
services will be exposed into Google
Cloud developers can go in there and
access the whole world of blockchain
data build web3 apps very quickly
without having to kind of manage and run
their own nodes for all the different
types of blockchains out there
it's our responsibility to protect your
privacy and Security in every product we
make so that every day you're safer with
Google
to help you quickly and effectively
identify and resolve cyber threats
we're excited to unveil
Chronicle security operations are Suite
that consolidates security analytics
security Automation and threat
intelligence
cyber security teams can now detect
investigate and respond to threats with
the speed scale and intelligence of
Google
please welcome Mandy and CEO Kevin
mandia to tell you more
Manion is known for being I believe the
best awarded threat intelligence we were
designed to know more about threat
actors than anybody else on the planet
and we are now combining our security
expertise and our threat Intel with the
AI and compute speed and analytics of
Google so we can bring this Vision to
everyone and as a result
we can effectively automate the often
human intensive process of understanding
the threat actors find a needle in the
haystack and be able to do shields up
against these attacks and together we
can deliver on that shared mission of a
more secure world
productivity of its people
I'm pleased now to invite aparna Papu
who leads Google workspace to share more
about the Direction with workspace
our mission is to meaningfully connect
people so that they can create build and
grow together
every time you use Gmail calendar docs
Drive chat Google me in your daily life
you are using workspace and to help
organizations thrive in a hybrid World
we've invested heavily in small canvas
our next Generation collaboration
experience and immersive connections our
approach to Bringing people together
through our communication products with
smart canvas a simple ad mention pulls
in the right people Data Insights in a
workflow directly in the places where
you're already working
here at Google we envision a whole new
era of communication expression and
co-creation
all powered by incredible advancements
in artificial intelligence
an era in which storytelling is richer
more expressive and frankly more fun
for generative AI unleashes people's
creativity and unlocks new workflows
when it comes to climate change people
governments and corporations are more
motivated than ever before
but they need access to the right
information to measure and improve upon
their EST commitments
today Google cloud is making it easier
for our customers to make better
sustainability decisions every single
day
I'm pleased to announce that Google
Cloud carbon footprint is now generally
available
and free for every user in the cloud
console
so that you can see and optimize your
carbon impact
I want to share my appreciation for all
of the people
who are building and transforming their
business with Google Cloud we're excited
to develop technology with the you
today
to help each of you
create a more amazing and a better
tomorrow
[Music]